hey guys I'm Ryan right now listen be
crazy here's the deal
ELISA just bought destiny PlayStation 4
that's 95 was it for PlayStation 4
she is pretty excited she's played a
little bit of it I just didn't want to
[ __ ] you guys cuz we're gonna watch
the trailer for destiny now I'm sure
there's gonna be things that alyssa has
yet to see I okay I purposely don't
watch any trailers for anything ever
so yeah that's a life oh that's what you
mean
so you come on the show yeah gotcha
Thole gotcha Alyssa you be correct I
love your name thank you and as a friend
I love you as a friend love you too
thanks so much thanks that means a lot
group here that means a lot
congratulations humans haven't been on
the moon in hundreds of years nice place
to visit but I wouldn't want to live
here dying here is much more likely nice
pep talk
looks like guardians of the galaxy mess
there's nothing I hate more than an
alien with no respect for history knock
knock who's there
whoa music oh
classical ah cool
Oh
damn
fifteen simple type of [ __ ] I can say
hello in any nice looks like you can say
goodbye to
what do you think is down there
dad there's our hours
Wow do you know I was a great trailer
that would make an amazing movie
wouldn't wait for that that will happen
it will happen one day dude that was
awesome it's got like I'm more like
modern-day version of Star Wars in a way
about it you know what I mean what just
happened I love Star Wars it's in my top
top of the top but destiny is nothing
like Star Wars I'm saying to look it
look like they were pod racing for a
second you have to play it I'll bring it
over you're gonna deny that it looked
like they were pod racing it's not
though but it totally looks like it
elissa it's not be [ __ ] enemy they
don't look like pod racers at all how
are you something happened do you want
to go back and look at it I know what it
looks like let's hope so I can't look at
guardians of the galaxy - you haven't
seen that so shush your mouth but it's
such a good game I'm so excited I just
picked it up at midnight with my Snow
White console and the puzzle packs so
awesome I set it up last night played it
up till 4:00 in the morning they woke up
after I thought I was already waiting I
realized I was so tired I fell asleep
and didn't realize it because I was
playing it for so long
Oh much fun quick question how stupid am
I gonna look if I keep that Star Wars
footage in there not very really it's
it's in space yeah that's staying in the
video hey guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe and Alyssa has
a channel too [ __ ] is a wild lone man
channel
and I'm also gonna be playing destiny ah
yeah subscribe to her Channel let's see
shoutouts Oh Mel Gibson hey guys I know
I hurt my family by my racist remarks
but I really love you guys and you
helped me forgive myself
dude mal that is [ __ ] awesome man I
am so proud that we were able to help
you recover from your alcohol addiction
from your you know your crazy
all abusive coins the best way to
devoted this show just got a little dark
yeah anyway
Darren Mortimer Ryan you look like
you're losing weight can i have a shout
out please he is
I am losing weight because I'm training
for Tough Mudder and I haven't been
training enough
currently I am sick I am currently sick
let me tell you something about
cvs/pharmacy
for a second those [ __ ] told me
in yes it's right aid no right it was
the wrong one that's the problem
you're not mad you got mad early whoa yo
you don't know over to Tracy yeah at
write a CVS for me one thirty they'd be
ready
we went there at five pharmacy and we're
at Rite Aid and he said yes we have the
right pharmacy don't you worry
so that's not the problem he still
wanted I've had her ready wrong pharmacy
they still wouldn't have had her ready
that's my point is if our methey she's
not getting it dude here's the order of
events I call at 12 o'clock they tell me
your prescription will be ready
that is CVS yes I stopped by writing it
was the wrong pharmacy but when I came
back I looked at the number and then CVS
told me they'd be ready by 1:30 and then
we got there like 4:30 and they said it
would be ready in 45 more minutes I see
what happened I gotcha
okay it was just for me well I came over
when we were at Rite Aid so I you know
yeah anyway we'll read it it's here more
number thanks I am losing weight and it
feels pretty damn good I do want to
shout you up because thanks for the
compliment man it you know how to
compliment a lady so thank you
David Melgar maybe one day Ryan give me
a shout out david Melgar you have the
same last name as my friend brandon
Melgar brandon owns a restaurant called
spice spice has delicious french toast
can we go yeah we can go I love french
toast so David thank you for letting me
take this time to promote my friend
Brandon Melgar in his restaurant but
today that's a you get to shut up oh
yeah you got your shadow I still send
your name that's what counts
right David right number Oh what you're
gonna give me attitude about it I
[ __ ] gave you a shout out what the
[ __ ] man dude dude yeah dude
look look I I know the
you were waiting a while but seriously
this sounds like it's a much deeper
rooted issue as to why you are upset
right now over not getting a full
shoutout so let's just take a moment and
try to analyze what's really going on
here
the medicine I took earlier made me
completely forget what the [ __ ] we were
just talking about